There are so many ways for friendships to fall apart. You move to different cities, you fall in love with somebody who your friend doesn't get, you have kids, you don't see each other as much. So that finally when you do see each other, it's not as comfortable. And you both sit there trying to make conversation, and you both wonder in your heads quietly, are we really friends? What do we have in common again?
友谊破裂的方式有很多。你们搬到了不同的城市，你爱上了一个朋友看不上的人，你们有了孩子，见面的次数变少了。以至于最后你们再见面时，已经没有那么自在了。你们俩坐在那儿努力找话题，心里却都在暗自嘀咕：我们真的是朋友吗？我们之间还有什么共同点吗？
And then you try to talk about all the stuff that you used to talk about when you were closer. And you feel like, oh, this is just going through the motions. And then, finally, it's time to go. And you say to each other, oh, let's do this again soon. And you don't even know what to think when you get home. And usually it takes years to get to this point. You at least get in a few good years together. It isn't that way from the start.
然后你们试图谈论那些过去亲近时常聊的话题。却觉得，哦，这不过是走过场而已。最后，时间到了，该走了。你们对彼此说，哦，我们要尽快再聚。当你回到家时，甚至不知道该想些什么。通常需要好几年才会到这一步。你们至少一起度过了几年美好时光。并不是从一开始就这样。
If you had met each other in Russia, what would have happened?
如果你们在俄罗斯相遇，会发生什么？
Nothing.
什么也不会发生。
什么也不会。
You never would have spoken again?
你们再也不会说话了吗？
Maybe if we will meet in some party, we'll just say hi. That's it.
也许如果在某个聚会上遇见，我们只会打个招呼。仅此而已。
Yeah, that will be it.
对，仅此而已。
Katya and Alla moved to America from Russia within a few months of each other to small towns near Flint, Michigan. Katya's sister-in-law invited them both to a party, hoping they'd meet, figuring, hey, they're both from Russia. Maybe they'll hit it off. But no. Here's Alla.
卡佳（Katya）和阿拉（Alla）在几个月内先后从俄罗斯搬到美国，住在密歇根州弗林特附近的小镇。卡佳的嫂子邀请她们去参加一个聚会，希望能让她们认识，心想，嘿，她们都来自俄罗斯。也许她们会合得来。但并没有。这是阿拉。
We tried to speak a little bit, but we did not have anything to say to each other.
我们尝试聊了一会儿，但我们之间没什么可说的。
Was it awkward? Or was it boring?
很尴尬吗？还是觉得无聊？
In the beginning, yeah.
刚开始的时候，是的。
So boring, so awkward, they didn't speak again for five months. But by then, both of them were so exhausted from trying to speak English all the time, they decided, hey, give it another shot. So they got together every week or so, which unfolded like a very long series of bad blind dates between people with no natural chemistry in Russian. Here's Katya.
太无聊、太尴尬了，以至于她们五个月没再说过话。但到那时，她们两个都因为一直试着说英语而精疲力竭，于是决定，嘿，再试一次吧。所以她们每周左右聚一次，这就像是一场发生在两个俄语背景下完全没有自然化学反应的人之间、长得离谱且糟糕的盲目约会。这是卡佳。
I just wanted to speak my language. Just to relax my brain, sit comfortably, and talk in Russian. But the more I talked to her, I was like, oh, my God, am I going to be friends with this girl ever? Is it possible?
我只是想说我的母语。想让大脑放松一下，舒服地坐着，用俄语聊天。但我和她聊得越多，我就越觉得，天哪，我以后真的能和这个女孩成为朋友吗？这可能吗？
Their opinions on so many things made no sense to each other. Katya thinks of herself as a cynical person. Her sense of humor can be a little mean. Alla's not so judgmental. She reads spiritual books, spends time with her kid. As Katya says, they're very different.
她们对很多事情的看法在对方看来都毫无道理。卡佳认为自己是个愤世嫉俗的人。她的幽默感有时有点刻薄。阿拉没那么爱评判别人。她读灵性书籍，花时间陪孩子。正如卡佳所说，她们非常不同。
Everything's different. Everything's different in our lives. Like, I don't have children. She does. And back in Russia, she was a teacher. And I was a doctor.
一切都不同。我们生活中的一切都不同。比如，我没有孩子，而她有。在俄罗斯时，她是老师，而我是医生。
Different age.
年龄也不同。
Difference in age. How much we got paid back in Russia.
年龄有差异。我们在俄罗斯拿的薪水也不同。
My husband is not so rich. And I did not work. I did not have my own money. And my husband could not allow me much money to spend with my friends, go to restaurants, go to fitness club. And I feel uncomfortable because Katya's husband gave her as much money as she needs. And so--
我丈夫没那么有钱。我没工作，没有自己的钱。我丈夫不能让我有很多钱去和朋友消费、去餐厅、去健身俱乐部。我觉得很不自在，因为卡佳的丈夫给了她所有她需要的钱。所以……
Not yet.
还没呢。
Did you just say, "not yet?"
你刚才说“还没呢”？
Not yet, yes.
还没呢，是的。
Now, as you can probably hear, after hanging out regularly for two years, they've gotten used to each other. Now they know more people in common. And those people provide a steady topic of conversation. And their feelings about each other have changed, some.
现在，正如你们可能听到的那样，在定期交往两年后，她们已经习惯了彼此。现在她们有了更多共同认识的人。而这些人提供了稳定的谈话主题。她们对彼此的感觉也发生了一些变化。
At the beginning, did you think of yourselves as real friends?
刚开始的时候，你们认为自己是真正的朋友吗？
No.
不。
No. No.
不。不。
Are you real friends now?
你们现在是真正的朋友了吗？
Can you describe how do you understand, Ira?
你能描述一下你是怎么理解的吗，艾拉（Ira）？
Real friends.
真正的朋友。
Yeah, real friends.
对，真正的朋友。
A real friend is somebody who you are comfortable with, who you would say real things to.
真正的朋友是那些让你感到自在，可以向他们倾诉真心话的人。
I think Katya is a very good friend for me. And I am very comfortable with her right now.
我觉得卡佳对我来说是个很好的朋友。我现在和她在一起感到非常自在。
I think that with Alla, I'm getting there, step by step. It takes a longer time for me to get used to her.
我觉得和阿拉在一起，我正在一步步接近。我习惯她需要更长的时间。
Yes, but sometimes if I do not call you one week, you will call back and ask, why do you not call me? I do not hear you one week already!
是的，但有时候如果我一周没给你打电话，你会回电话问，为什么不给我打？我都一周没听到你的声音了！
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, The Ties That Bind, stories of friendships that somehow keep existing for reasons that are not always so clear to anybody. And, in fact, one or more people of the people in the friendship wonder if it's a real friendship. I was just going to say, is there a name for this particular kind of friend? Do we have a word for that kind of friend? And we do. That word is friend.
那么，这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》（This American Life），由国际公共广播电台（Public Radio International）发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。今天的节目是《羁绊》，讲述那些因为某些对任何人来说都不太明确的原因而持续存在的友谊。事实上，友谊中的一个人或多个人会怀疑这是否是一段真正的友谊。我正想说，这种特别的朋友有名字吗？我们有形容那种朋友的词吗？我们确实有。那个词就是“朋友”。
Our show today in four acts. Act One, Fred and Barney. In that act, an inside look at a long, troubled relationship in the town of Bedrock. Act Two, Lucas and Sarah. Two families get friendly because of their kids, though it's a friendship, I think, neither family would have wanted, actually. Act Three, Lucy and the Bike Girl, two friends who are supposed to stay apart no matter what. Act Four, David and Andi. A casual comment between strangers turns into something much, much bigger. Stay with us.
我们今天的节目分为四幕。第一幕，弗雷德（Fred）和巴尼（Barney）。在这一幕中，我们将深入了解石层镇（Bedrock）一段长期且充满矛盾的关系。第二幕，卢卡斯（Lucas）和莎拉（Sarah）。两个家庭因为孩子而变得亲近，虽然我认为，这是两个家庭实际上都不想要的那种友谊。第三幕，露西（Lucy）和骑车女孩，两个无论如何都应该保持距离的朋友。第四幕，大卫（David）和安迪（Andi）。陌生人之间的一次随意交谈演变成了极其重大的事情。请继续收听。
Act One, Fred and Barney. This first story comes from Jonathan Goldstein and David Rakoff. As we all know, back before the Iron Age and the Bronze Age, back in the Stone Age, as primitive as the conditions were back then, cavemen did have answering machines. And friendships were just as complicated as they are today.
第一幕，弗雷德和巴尼。第一个故事来自乔纳森·戈德斯坦（Jonathan Goldstein）和大卫·拉科夫（David Rakoff）。众所周知，在铁器时代和青铜时代之前，在石器时代，即使当时的条件极其原始，穴居人也有电话答录机。而友谊也和今天一样复杂。
[PHONE DIALING]
（电话拨号声）
[PHONE RINGING]
（电话铃声）
You have reached the answering machine of Fred and Wilma Flintstone. Please leave us a message after the beep.
你已接通弗雷德和威尔玛·弗林特斯通（Fred and Wilma Flintstone）的答录机。请在哔声后留言。
[BEEP]
（哔声）
Hey Fred, it's Barney. Fred, I, um-- listen, I don't know how to even tell you this, but I was pulling out of the driveway, and I accidentally ran over Dino. He's dead, Fred. I'm really, really, really sorry. I-- he was sleeping on our driveway behind the car. I just backed up over him. I didn't see him or anything. I hate to be leaving something like this on your answering machine.
嘿弗雷德，我是巴尼。弗雷德，我，嗯……听着，我不知道该怎么告诉你，但刚才我把车开出车道时，不小心撞到了迪诺（Dino）。他死了，弗雷德。我真的很抱歉。我……他当时睡在我们车道上的车后面。我倒车时直接压过了他。我根本没看见他。我真不想在你的答录机里留这种话。
The thing is, Betty and I have to get to the airport because we're supposed to make our flight to Rock-apulco. I don't know what to do. I almost canceled the trip. But everything's booked. And Betty's been really, really looking forward to it for so long. Honestly, I don't know what to do. I'll try calling you as soon as the plane lands, OK? I'm sorry, Fred.
问题是，贝蒂（Betty）和我要去赶飞机，因为我们得去洛克阿普尔科（Rock-apulco）。我不知道该怎么办。我差点取消行程。但一切都订好了。贝蒂期待这一趟很久很久了。老实说，我不知道该怎么办。飞机一落地我就给你打电话，好吗？对不起，弗雷德。
[PHONE RINGING]
（电话铃声）
This is Barney.
我是巴尼。
This is Betty.
我是贝蒂。
We're the Rubbles.
我们是拉布尔（Rubble）夫妇。
But we can't find our cell phone.
但我们找不到手机了。
I thought you had it.
我以为在你那儿。
Oh no.
哦，不。
Better just leave us a message.
还是给我们留言吧。
Heh, heh, heh, heh.
呵，呵，呵，呵。
[BEEP]
（哔声）
Uh, hi Barney. It's Fred. I'm just-- I don't know. I'm sad and stunned and-- I don't know. I guess you're still on the flight to Rock-apulco. Call me when you land.
呃，嗨巴尼。我是弗雷德。我只是……我不知道。我很伤心，也很震惊，而且……我不知道。我想你们还在去洛克阿普尔科的飞机上。落地了给我打电话。
[PHONE RINGING]
（电话铃声）
This is Barney.
我是巴尼。
This is Betty.
我是贝蒂。
We're the Rubbles.
我们是拉布尔夫妇。
But we can't find our cell phone.
但我们找不到手机了——
I thought you had it.
我以为在你那儿。
Oh no.
哦，不。
Better just leave us a message.
还是给我们留言吧。
Heh, heh, heh, heh.
呵，呵，呵，呵。
[BEEP]
（哔声）
Hi, it's Fred again. Still no word from you. And by my calculations, you should have landed by now. Just try to give a call, OK?
嗨，又是弗雷德。还是没有你们的消息。按我的计算，你们现在应该落地了。试着打个电话，好吗？
[PHONE RINGING]
（电话铃声）
This is Barney.
我是巴尼。
This is Betty.
我是贝蒂。
We're the Rubbles.
我们是拉布尔夫妇。
But we can't find our cell phone--
但我们找不到手机——
Hi Barney. I don't know if you remember me. We were best friends, and then you killed my dinosaur. Let's see, when was that? Oh, yeah. This morning. I can tell you're broken up about it because you've tried to call me zero times.
嗨巴尼。不知道你还记不记得我。我们曾是最好的朋友，然后你杀了我的恐龙。让我想想，那是什么时候？哦，对了。今天早上。我看得出你对此很难过，因为你一次都没打给我。
[BEEP]
（哔声）
Fred, I just got off the plane this second, and I just got all your messages. Don't ask what we just went through. Anyway, the pterodactyl that flew us here broke a wing, and I pretty much thought that was it. Fred, I saw my whole life pass before my eyes. And there was plenty of me and you in there. Do you remember the time you hypnotized me into thinking I was a puppy? I could just go on and on.
弗雷德，我刚才下了飞机，刚刚才收到你所有的信息。别问我们刚经历了什么。总之，载我们来的翼龙折断了一根翅膀，我当时真以为没命了。弗雷德，我眼睁睁看着我的一生在眼前闪过。里面全是我们俩的回忆。还记得那次你催眠我，让我以为自己是一只小狗吗？我能说个没完。
I feel just awful, but what the hell can I do? I mean, do you want me to slit Hop-a-Roo's throat? Would that make you feel better? If I murdered my kid's kangaroo? I mean, not to minimize your pain or anything, but it is only a dinosaur. You realize that, right?
我感觉糟透了，但除了这样我还能干什么？我是说，你想要我割开霍普阿鲁（Hop-a-Roo）的喉咙吗？那样会让你好受点吗？如果我杀了我孩子的小袋鼠？我是说，并不是要淡化你的痛苦，但那终究只是一只恐龙。你意识到这一点了吧？
I'm sorry. That was stupid. I'm sorry. Look, I'm just freaked out. Listen, when you get a chance, just try me back on my cell. It seems to be working here. OK, bye pal.
对不起。那是蠢话。对不起。听着，我只是被吓坏了。听着，有机会的话，回拨我的手机。它现在好像能用了。好啦，再见，老伙计。
[BEEP]
（哔声）
God, Barney, I am so, so sorry. I had no idea you had plane trouble. Wow. Funny, while you were leaving me that message, I was actually on the other line with Raptor Air, and they had no record of wing problems on the Bedrock/Rock-apulco flight. But I mean, what do they know? They're just the airline, right? It's probably just a cover up so there are no lawsuits.
天哪，巴尼，我真的、真的非常抱歉。我不知道你们遇上了飞行事故。哇。真有趣，当你给我留那条信息的时候，我实际上正在和猛禽航空（Raptor Air）通话，他们那儿根本没有关于石层镇到洛克阿普尔科航班翅膀故障的记录。但我的意思是，他们懂什么？他们只是航空公司，对吧？这可能只是掩盖事实，为了不让别人起诉。
Man, you must have been so shaken up. And still, you managed to call me the minute you got off the plane. And got through customs. And rented a car. And drove to the resort. And checked in. There are no accidents. Think about that when you're trying to explain how a pipsqueak could even get his foreign compact car to run all the way over a nearly full-grown dinosaur, let alone kill it. I mean, how many times did you have to back up over Dino?
伙计，你一定被吓坏了。即便如此，你还是在下飞机的那一刻就给我打了电话。还过完了海关。还租了车。还开了车去度假村。还办理了入住。这世上没有巧合。想想看，当你试图解释一辆小不点儿的外国紧凑型车是怎么在几乎完全长大的恐龙身上开过去，甚至把它杀死的。我是说，你到底倒车压了迪诺多少次？
And no, I don't want you to murder your kid's kangaroo. If anything, that privilege should fall to me. So I will just leave you with this one thought. Why don't you ask Betty why it took her so long for her and me to get those bronco burger buns at the grocery store two Sundays ago? Go on, just ask her. Have fun.
而且不，我不需要你杀死你孩子的小袋鼠。如果非要说的话，那个特权应该归我。所以我只想留给你一个想法。你为什么不问问贝蒂，为什么两周前的那个周日，她在杂货店买那些野牛汉堡面包花那么长时间？去问问吧，去问她。玩得开心。
[BEEP]
（哔声）
Stony Curtis made out with Wilma. You think I'm lying? Remember when we were visiting the set of Slave Boy and we heard her screaming in ecstasy from inside the trailer? And how after you asked her what was going on in there, and she said she had accidentally sat on a porcupine quill? And she and Stony started laughing? What the hell do you think they were laughing about, you poor, ignorant, fat boob?
斯托尼·柯蒂斯（Stony Curtis）和威尔玛亲热了。你觉得我在撒谎？还记得我们参观《奴隶男孩》（Slave Boy）片场时，听到她在拖车里发出狂喜的尖叫声吗？之后你问她怎么回事，她说是不小心坐到豪猪刺上了？然后她和斯托尼开始大笑？你这可怜、无知、肥胖的傻瓜，你觉得他们在笑什么？
And as far as your disgusting, disgusting insinuation about my wife, let me tell you something, Fred. Betty has never liked you. She's only ever tolerated you out of respect to me, and out of love for Wilma. I'm the only friend you have, Fred. And I'd always tell people, "aw, Fred, he's all right. He doesn't mean all the mean things he says. That's his bluster. Underneath it all, he's got a really good heart." Bull crap. I was a sucker, Fred.
至于你对我妻子那令人作呕、令人作呕的影射，让我告诉你一件事，弗雷德。贝蒂从来没喜欢过你。她仅仅是出于对我的尊重，以及对威尔玛的爱才一直容忍你。我是你唯一的朋友，弗雷德。我总是告诉别人，“噢，弗雷德，他这人还行。他说那些刻薄的话并不是故意的。那是他的虚张声势。在他内心深处，他有一颗真正善良的心。”鬼话。我当时真是个蠢货，弗雷德。
[BEEP]
（哔声）
Oh, boy, are you deluded. Wilma doesn't need Stony Curtis. Some wives are actually happy with their husbands. "Screams of ecstasy." You need to have your ears checked, buddy. Because they must have been playing tricks on you. So as a favor to you, for future reference, I'm going to give you an abject lesson in what screaming in ecstasy sounds like, OK?
噢，孩子，你真是被蒙蔽了。威尔玛不需要斯托尼·柯蒂斯。有些妻子对她们的丈夫其实很满意。“狂喜的尖叫声”。你需要去检查一下耳朵了，伙计。因为它们一定是在和你开玩笑。所以为了帮你，为了以后作为参考，我要给你上一堂关于狂喜的尖叫声听起来是什么样的课程，好吗？
OK, I'm out my door. I'm walking to your house. It's chilly out tonight. I'm getting the key from under the tortoise out front. I'm walking inside your house. Opening the closet to get out your driving iron from your golf bag. Where should I go? Let's see.
好吧，我要出门了。我正走去你家。今晚外面真冷。我从前门的乌龟下面拿钥匙。我走进你家了。打开壁橱拿你的高尔夫球杆。我该去哪儿？让我想想。
How about that case of bowling trophies? [SOUNDS OF DESTRUCTION] Oh, yeah. That feels good. Oh, yeah! Bam! Woo! Yeah! Do you hear me, Barn? This is what ecstasy sounds like. Do you like it?
那箱保龄球奖杯怎么样？（破坏的声音）噢，对了。那感觉真棒。噢，对了！砰！呜！耶！你听到了吗，巴恩？这就是狂喜听起来的样子。你喜欢吗？
[PHONE RINGING]
（电话铃声）
You have reached the home of the Rubbles.
你已接通拉布尔家。
Come here, Bamm-Bamm. Say hi to the nice people.
过来，班班（Bamm-Bamm）。跟好心人打个招呼。
[BAMM-BAMM SPEAKING NONSENSE]
（班班发出胡言乱语）
Please leave a message.
请留言。
Heh, heh, heh, heh.
呵，呵，呵，呵。
[BEEP]
（哔声）
Fred, get the hell out of my house. Do you hear me, Fred? Pick it up, you sick SOB. Pick it up, you sick son of a-- [MICROPHONE FEEDBACK] Hey, Fred?
弗雷德，给我滚出我家。你听到了吗，弗雷德？接电话，你这个变态的混蛋。接电话，你这个变态的……（麦克风反馈声）嘿，弗雷德？
I can't catch my breath. Give me a sec.
我喘不上气了。给我几秒钟。
Well, sit down. Where are you? The living room?
好吧，坐下。你在哪儿？客厅？
Yeah.
是的。
Lean forward and keep your head down.
身体前倾，头低下。
OK.
好吧。
Did you eat today?
你今天吃饭了吗？
I can't remember. Maybe.
我不记得了。可能吃了。
Well, that's probably why you're dizzy. I think Betty left some food in the fridge.
嗯，那可能就是你头晕的原因。我想贝蒂冰箱里应该还有吃的。
OK. One sec. I don't know what it was, this-- is this lasagna? It looks like lasagna. What was this?
好吧。等一下。我不知道这是什么，这……这是千层肉酱面吗？看起来像千层肉酱面。这是什么？
Oh, yeah. That was good. Have some of that.
噢，对了。那个很好吃。吃点那个。
All right. So did you eat today?
好吧。那你今天吃了吗？
Oh, yeah. They've got a really nice buffet here. Very nice fruit.
噢，吃了。他们这儿有很棒的自助餐。很好的水果。
Oh, that's good. It's fresh, huh?
噢，那很好。很新鲜，是吧？
Oh, it's right off the tree.
噢，刚从树上摘下来的。
Nice.
不错。
Yeah. Fred, I'm really sorry about Dino.
是啊。弗雷德，关于迪诺，我真的很抱歉。
I know you are. I'm sorry about-- with Betty.
我知道。关于……贝蒂的事，我很抱歉。
Yeah, I have some stuff I need to deal with. That's kind of why we were taking this trip.
是的，我有些事情需要处理。这也是我们为什么会来这趟旅行的原因。
Barney? Barney, are you crying?
巴尼？巴尼，你在哭吗？
You wake up one day. And you're like a stranger to yourself, you know? I don't know who I am anymore. I can't be a husband to my wife. And I have a son who's disturbingly aggressive.
有一天你醒来。你会觉得像是个陌生人，你知道吗？我不知道我是谁了。我没法做一个称职的丈夫。而且我有一个令人不安的、极具攻击性的儿子。
Oh, no, no, Barn, I mean, Bamm-Bamm's OK.
噢，不，不，巴恩，我是说，班班没事的。
No, he's not, Fred. He's awful. He's just so violent. He breaks everything. And I can't make Betty happy. This morning, I was standing in the ocean. And it was just a really, really beautiful day. But all I could think, as I was standing there in the ocean, was just, keep walking, Barney. Walk out to sea and never come back. No one will miss you.
不，他不是，弗雷德。他很可怕。他太暴力了。他什么都砸。而且我没法让贝蒂快乐。今天早上，我站在海里。那是个非常、非常美好的一天。但我当时站在海里时，脑子里只想的一件事就是，继续走下去，巴尼。走进大海，永远别回来。没有人会想念你。
Hey! Hey, don't talk about my little buddy that way. It would destroy Betty. I mean, it would destroy her. I would miss you.
嘿！嘿，别那样说我的小哥们。那会摧毁贝蒂的。我是说，那会毁了她。我会想你的。
You would?
你会吗？
Of course I would. I wouldn't know what to do with myself. You think I'm a rage-aholic now.
我当然会。我不知道没你我该怎么办。你觉得我现在是个暴怒狂是吧。
Hey, while you're in the house, can you make sure I put out a dish of water for the pelican trash can?
嘿，既然你在屋子里，你能帮我确保给鹈鹕垃圾桶放上一碗水吗？
Um, yeah, it looks like you did.
嗯，是的，看起来你放了。
I hate when you get home and you find them sucking at the pipes under the sink. It makes coming home so sad.
我最讨厌回家发现它们在吮吸水槽下的管道。这让回家变得太伤感了。
You ever get that thing where you come home after being away for a while, and your own house smells all weird? Like, you can actually smell what it really smells like because you're not used to it anymore?
你有没有那种经历，离家一段时间后再回来，觉得家里闻起来怪怪的？就像是因为你不再习惯那种味道了，所以你能闻出它真实的样子？
Yeah, I know what you mean.
是的，我明白你的意思。
Listen, have a good time. Don't get all depressed.
听着，玩得开心。别太沮丧了。
Listen, you don't get all depressed, too, with all this blowhard stuff. My best buddy isn't any blowhard, OK?
听着，你也别因为这些虚张声势的事情而太沮丧。我最好的兄弟才不是什么虚张声势的人，好吗？
Yeah, yeah.
是的，是的。
Listen, when I get home, things will get back to normal. We'll sit down and we'll play a hand of bridge with the girls. And it'll be like it always is.
听着，等我回家后，一切都会恢复正常的。我们会坐下来和女孩们玩一把桥牌。一切都会像往常一样。
Yeah, sure, Barn.
是的，当然，巴恩。
And I'll bring back some of that famous Rock-apulco honeydew. And it'll be great.
我会带回一些那儿著名的洛克阿普尔科蜜瓜。那会很棒的。
Yeah, I mean, yabba-dabba-doo!
是的，我是说，亚巴达巴多（Yabba-dabba-doo）！
David Rock-off as Fred, and before him, Jonathan Gold-stone as Barney. And as Betty, Wendy Dorr, whose name is weirdly impervious to stone and rock punnage. She also produced this story, a version of which is also run on Jonathan's radio show WireTap, which is heard on the CBC and on some public radio stations here in our country as well.
大卫·拉科夫饰演弗雷德，在他之前，乔纳森·戈德斯坦饰演巴尼。饰演贝蒂的温迪·多尔（Wendy Dorr），她的名字真是奇怪地不受石头和岩石双关语的影响。她也制作了这个故事，该故事的一个版本也在乔纳森的广播节目《WireTap》中播出，该节目在加拿大广播公司和我国的一些公共广播电台也能听到。
Act Two, Lucas and Sarah. Sometimes you have just one thing in common with somebody else, and then you have to figure out if that connection means anything more, if you're supposed to be friends or something. And it's especially hard to figure out if you feel obligated to the other person in some way. Jill Wolfson has this story.
第二幕，卢卡斯和莎拉。有时你和某个人只有一件事有共同点，然后你必须弄清楚这种联系是否有其他意义，如果你们应该成为朋友之类的。而且如果你在某种程度上觉得对另一个人有负债感，就更难弄清楚了。吉尔·沃尔夫森（Jill Wolfson）带来了这个故事。
For a lot of her childhood, Sarah knew there was something wrong with her. Ordinary kid games would leave her exhausted and panting for breath. In one year, when she was eight, she went to the doctor 14 times. Then, when Sarah finished fifth grade, her heart failed. She needed a transplant. She was 11.
在童年的大部分时间里，莎拉都知道自己出了问题。普通的孩子游戏会让她筋疲力尽，气喘吁吁。在她八岁那年，她去看医生看了14次。后来，莎拉小学五年级毕业时，她的心脏衰竭了。她需要进行移植。她当时11岁。
In the hospital, she had to stay flat on her back to prevent a stroke. To keep her weight as low as possible, she was fed intravenously. She had to pass up two hearts that became available because both times she was fighting off infection. Hundreds of people die waiting for a heart each year, and someone Sarah's age typically waits months and months, if they're lucky enough to even get one. But Sarah didn't have that kind of time. Her kidneys were also shutting down. And then, some news.
在医院里，她必须平躺在床上以防止中风。为了保持尽可能低的体重，她只能通过静脉注射来获取营养。她错过了两次获得心脏的机会，因为那两次她都在对抗感染。每年有成百上千的人在等待心脏移植中去世，而像莎拉这么大的孩子如果幸运的话，通常也要等上好几个月。但莎拉没有那么多的时间。她的肾脏也在衰竭。然后，传来了一些消息。
It was a Friday night. And I was really hungry. And they had just started letting me eat again, because I was being fed intravenously. And then my tray was in the room. And my dad was sitting with me. And all of a sudden, I was really excited I was going to eat. And then, they came in and took the tray out. And I was really upset. I was like, Dad go find out why they took the tray out. I don't understand. I'm really hungry. And so he goes [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. And they tell him that there's a heart.
那是一个周五的晚上。我真的很饿。他们刚开始让我进食，因为之前一直通过静脉注射进食。我的餐盘就在房间里。我爸爸正陪着我。突然，我特别兴奋能吃饭了。然后，他们进来把餐盘拿走了。我特别难过。我说，爸爸，去问问他们为什么把餐盘拿走。我不明白。我真的好饿。所以他去（听不清）。他们告诉他，有一颗心脏了。
Sarah's mom, Laura.
莎拉的妈妈，劳拉（Laura）。
David, her dad, called, and goes, Well, it's a heart. We've got one. Well, we just started screaming and jumping up and down and dancing.
她爸爸大卫打电话过来说，嗯，是一颗心脏。我们有了一颗。然后我们就开始尖叫、蹦跳、跳舞。
My heart, since it was three times the size that it should have been, the heart cavity was really large. And the donor that I got it from, even though the person was my age, the heart fit well because it was a little bit bigger but still healthy. And so, it fit well. And even though the cavity's larger, it works. It fits.
我的心脏，因为它比正常大三倍，所以心腔非常大。虽然捐赠者和我年龄相仿，但那颗心脏大小适中，因为它稍微大一点点，但还是很健康。所以，它很合适。尽管心腔比较大，但它能用。它很合适。
I remember the surgeon telling us that it was a perfect heart.
我记得外科医生告诉我们，那是一颗完美的心脏。
What do you remember about post-surgery?
关于术后你记得什么？
Oh, my gosh. The first moment I came out of the medicine that they put me on, I remember feeling like I was drowning-- I'm going to cry thinking about it-- because I hadn't breathed so good for so long. And all of a sudden I just felt like I was drowning in air. And it was just-- It was really cool.
哦，天哪。我从麻醉药物中醒来的那一刻，我记得那种感觉就像是在溺水——想到这里我就想哭——因为我太久没有呼吸得那么好了。突然之间我感觉自己沉浸在空气中。那真是……那真的很棒。
And the first time I got to come in and see her afterwards, I touched her feet. And you have to understand that her feet had been so cold for so long. And I had been warned that her feet were going to be warm. And I touched them, and they were warm. And then that's when I knew that things were working good.
第一次看到她的时候，我摸了摸她的脚。你要知道她的脚已经冰冷太久了。我被告知她的脚会变暖。我摸了摸它们，它们是温热的。那时候我就知道，一切都好起来了。
For most families, this is where it would end. Maybe a thank you note passed through a social worker to the donor family. But Sarah's mom, Laura, wanted more. Whoever gave her daughter this heart had done something so important to their family, it felt strange not to know them better.
对于大多数家庭来说，到这里就结束了。也许是一封通过社工传达给捐赠者家庭的感谢信。但莎拉的妈妈劳拉想要更多。那个给了她女儿心脏的人为他们的家庭做了如此重要的事情，如果不够了解他们，会觉得很奇怪。
But hospitals don't just casually release personal information. Donor families might get upset hearing directly from someone who's walking around with their loved one's heart. And a lot of recipients don't want to be reminded where their organs came from, either. Sarah felt that way.
但医院不会随随便便泄露个人信息。捐赠者家庭听到一个带着他们亲人心脏走来走去的人的消息可能会感到不安。很多接受器官移植的人也不想被提醒器官来自哪里。莎拉就有这种感觉。
I don't know. I didn't really want to know. Because it's really personal but also it's insane. You don't know how to have a relationship with the people who saved your life. It's just really strange. I felt bad. I felt really guilty.
我不知道。我真的不想知道。因为它非常私人，而且太疯狂了。你不知道该如何与救了你命的人保持关系。这真的很奇怪。我感到很难过。我感到非常内疚。
And I know it's not my fault that the person died, but you can't really help but feel bad to benefit from someone that's lost someone, you know? And that was the hardest thing. I didn't want to meet them and feel guilty about their child passing away.
我知道那个人的去世不是我的错，但你真的忍不住因为别人的丧子之痛而获益而感到难过，你知道吗？那是最难受的事情。我不想见到他们，然后为他们的孩子去世感到内疚。
Sarah's mom, Laura, though, didn't give up. And the hospital did give Laura a few basic details. The heart had come from a boy about Sarah's age who lived in the Fresno area, about two and a half hours from where Laura and Sarah lived. Laura's relatives went online and started doing some sleuthing. They discovered a boy named Lucas who lived in the Fresno area. He died just before Sarah's transplant. His cause of death, murder.
莎拉的妈妈劳拉却没有放弃。医院确实给了劳拉一些基本信息。心脏来自弗雷斯诺（Fresno）地区一个和莎拉年龄相仿的男孩，离劳拉和莎拉住的地方大约两个半小时车程。劳拉的亲戚上网开始侦探调查。他们发现了一个住在弗雷斯诺地区叫卢卡斯的男孩。他在莎拉移植前不久去世。死因：谋杀。
The investigation stalled there. Until one day, a couple of months after the transplant, Laura did something hospitals discourage transplant families from trying. She happened to be near Fresno on business. She stopped by the local newspaper to go through the archives.
调查在那里陷入停滞。直到移植手术几个月后的某一天，劳拉做了一件医院不建议移植家庭尝试的事情。她正好因为公务在弗雷斯诺附近。她顺道去了当地报社查阅档案。
Lucas, the article said, was killed in an especially senseless crime. Members of one street gang taunted another. Bottles broke. A car window was smashed. Two men seeking revenge entered the home of a rival gang member, a 16-year-old named Arcadio, who just happened to be Lucas' brother.
文章说，卢卡斯死于一场特别无意义的犯罪。一个街头帮派的成员挑衅另一个帮派。瓶子破碎。汽车窗户被砸烂。两名寻求报复的男子闯入了一名敌对帮派成员的家，那个16岁名叫阿尔卡迪奥（Arcadio）的少年，正好是卢卡斯的哥哥。
When the intruder saw a sleeping figure, his face covered by a blanket, one of them fired three shots into his skull. But instead of their target, Arcadio, they executed Lucas, his innocent, 11-year-old, big-for-his-age brother. Reading all this just made Laura want more information.
当入侵者看到一个熟睡的身影，脸被毯子盖住时，其中一人对着他的头骨开了三枪。但他们执行的对象不是目标阿尔卡迪奥，而是他那无辜的、11岁、个头偏大的弟弟卢卡斯。读到这一切让劳拉想要更多信息。
In the articles in the paper, they gave his street name. I drove down his street, just really feeling the necessity to see where this boy was from. Not knowing what the actual address was of the house, I did stop some kids that were playing in the street and asked them if down the street is where the boy was shot. And they pointed out that, yes, it was the sunshine house, they called it. It was this yellow house. A very small house, very rough part of Fresno. And I drove by, and I could see people inside.
报纸文章里给了他的街道名称。我开车沿着他的街道行驶，真实地感受到必须看看这个男孩来自哪里。不知道房子的具体地址，我确实拦住了一些在街上玩的孩子，问他们街道那头是不是那个男孩被枪杀的地方。他们指着说，是的，就是那栋“阳光房”，他们这么叫。那是一栋黄色的房子。弗雷斯诺一个非常粗糙的地区。我开车经过，可以看到里面有人。
And then I actually went to the elementary school that was referenced in the newspaper, again, just really feeling the need to walk through, because he was Sarah's age. Anyway, I went into the school. The school was already closed, because it was in the late afternoon. I ran across a teacher who asked me what I was doing. And he said Lucas was his student.
然后我真的去了报纸提到的那所小学，又是真的觉得需要进去走一走，因为他跟莎拉一样大。总之，我进了学校。学校已经关门了，因为是下午晚些时候。我碰巧遇到了一个老师，问我在干什么。他说卢卡斯是他的学生。
So he brought in the classroom, showed me Lucas' desk. They had kept it the same. He told me all about Lucas. It was very emotional. In fact, just thinking now, my feelings are coming back. Just thinking that these were the items of the child that has saved my daughter's life, given her a second chance.
于是他把我带进教室，给我看了卢卡斯的书桌。他们一直保持原样。他告诉我所有关于卢卡斯的事。非常感人。事实上，现在想起来，我的感觉又回来了。想到这些正是那个救了我女儿生命、给了她第二次机会的孩子的遗物。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（说西班牙语）
I met with Lucas' family in rural Washington state, where they now live. They moved from California several years ago for work and to get away from gangs and bad memories. The parents, Maria and Miguel, share a home with Arcadio, his wife Karatina, and their four young children. We sat in their small living room, talking about their decision to donate their son's organs.
我在华盛顿州农村见到了卢卡斯的家人，他们现在住在那里。几年前为了工作和逃离帮派与不好的记忆，他们从加州搬走了。父母玛丽亚（Maria）和米格尔（Miguel）与阿尔卡迪奥、他的妻子卡拉蒂娜（Karatina）以及四个幼小的孩子住在一起。我们坐在他们狭小的客厅里，谈论他们捐赠儿子器官的决定。
The thing in our tradition is that we do not donate organs.
我们的传统是不捐赠器官的。
This is Basilica, Lucas' older sister, who talked them through the decision.
这是巴西利卡（Basilica），卢卡斯的大姐，她开导他们做了这个决定。
We had nobody ever in the family had ever donated organs to anybody. So my parents were thinking if it's all right to do that, because they didn't know if my brother was going to rest in peace knowing that part of him is living. And how does she know if he's really resting? Or she doesn't know if he was going to be mad.
我们家从来没有人给别人捐过器官。所以我父母在思考这么做是不是对的，因为他们不知道我弟弟能不能安息，在知道他身体的一部分还活着的情况下。而且她怎么知道他是不是真的安息了？或者她不知道他会不会生气。
And I told my parents that it's all right, because after you die, you don't feel nothing. It's like if you were asleep. When you're sleeping, you're not just walking around, or your spirit's going everywhere. And that it was all right.
我告诉我的父母，这没关系，因为死后你什么都感觉不到。就像在睡觉一样。当你睡觉时，你不是到处走动，也不是灵魂到处飘。所以这么做是可以的。
We talked about Lucas. And the family brought out photos and told the kinds of stories you'd expect. He was well-liked in school. He did nice things for his newborn niece. The only one who told darker stories about Lucas was his mom, Maria. In her stories, he was cranky with her. He'd sulk in his room a lot, or complain that she hadn't given him the food he wanted.
我们谈到了卢卡斯。家人拿出了照片，讲了你们预料之中的故事。他在学校里很受欢迎。他为刚出生的侄女做了很好的事情。唯一一个讲卢卡斯黑暗故事的人是他妈妈玛丽亚。在她的故事里，他很爱发脾气。他会躲在房间里生闷气，或者抱怨她没给他想吃的食物。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（说西班牙语）
She said that he would get mad sometimes. And he would tell her, I want to die. I wish I would die.
她说他有时会很生气。他会告诉她，我想要死。我希望我能死。
This is Karatina, Arcadio's wife, translating.
这是卡拉蒂娜，阿尔卡迪奥的妻子，正在翻译。
And he would tell her, what would she feel if he was to die, if she would cry? And she said that she would tell him, you're not going to die. You're going to be OK. And don't say those things. And she would get mad at him, and upset. And she would say that she would cry. She's going to cry if something happens to him.
他会告诉她，如果他死了，她会有什么感觉，她会哭吗？她说她会告诉他，你不会死的。你会没事的。别说那种话。她会对他生气，很难受。她说她会哭的。如果他发生什么事，她会哭的。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（说西班牙语）
Maria still feels a lot of guilt that she didn't do enough, wasn't there enough for her son. She wasn't at home the night Lucas was killed. She and her husband were many hours away, working in the fields as migrant laborers. Her daughter Basilica says she's never really forgiven herself.
玛丽亚仍然感到非常内疚，因为她做得不够，没有给儿子足够的陪伴。卢卡斯被杀的那晚，她并不在家。她和丈夫在很多小时外的地方，作为季节性工人在地里干活。她的女儿巴西利卡说她从来没有真正原谅过自己。
Yeah, the guilt of that she would leave us with other people. And that she would go a week or two, or a couple of months, because they would have to travel. And the guilt won't leave her.
是的，那种她把我们留在别人身边，自己一走就是一两周，或者几个月，因为不得不去旅行的内疚。那种内疚感一直不离她而去。
No, and it won't. I think to this day, it's always anger. Because when we go to one of the school's functions for the kids, and she gets mad at herself. We're walking to the car or home or something. Ay, how come I never did this with my son? she always says. He would tell me and I would never do it. I was dumb, she always says. And she gets mad at herself because she wasn't more involved in their life. She was just always working and working and working.
不，它不会消失。我想直到今天，那依然是愤怒。因为当我们去学校参加孩子们的活动时，她会生自己的气。我们在走去车子或家里什么地方时。哎，我为什么从没和儿子一起做过这个？她总是说。他会告诉我就去做，但我从没做过。我是个笨蛋，她总是说。她生自己的气，因为她没能更多地参与他们的生活。她只是不停地工作、工作、工作。
There was a lot of guilt to go around. Arcadio, now in his mid-20s, is soft spoken and kind of shy, not one to show his feelings easily. But after the shooting, Karatina would come home to find him sobbing, a picture of Lucas clenched to his chest. Like Sarah, Arcadio understood that he was alive only because Lucas was dead.
有太多的内疚需要分担。阿尔卡迪奥，现在20多岁，说话轻声细语，比较害羞，不是那种容易流露感情的人。但在枪击事件发生后，卡拉蒂娜回家总会发现他在抽泣，胸前紧紧抱着卢卡斯的照片。像莎拉一样，阿尔卡迪奥明白他活着仅仅是因为卢卡斯死了。
I had the guilt that it was my fault. And that had me for a long time like that. Some of my family blamed me. And they said in front of me at the hospital that because of me, and that's why. Because I was--
我有种内疚感，觉得是我的错。那种感觉折磨了我很久。我的一些家人责怪我。他们在医院里当着我的面说，是因为我，就是这样。因为我是——
He would just feel guilty all the time. He was kind of not there. He was out of it. And I would always--
他会一直感到内疚。他当时不在状态。他精神恍惚。我总是——
[INAUDIBLE] drugs, actually.
（听不清）毒品，实际上。
And I would always find him-- he was living a bad life. He was going down a bad road because of it.
我总是发现他——他过着糟糕的生活。他因为那件事走上了一条邪路。
Yeah, since that happened, some people would blame it on me. And I went with that guilt for a long time. For, like, eight years, I was addicted to drugs.
是的，自从那件事发生，有些人会把它归咎于我。我带着那种内疚感过了很久。大概有八年吧，我沉迷于毒品。
It was hard to make him realize that God didn't choose him to leave. He chose Lucas. And he was alive and he needed to act like it.
很难让他意识到，上帝选择让他离开的不是他。上帝选择了卢卡斯。而他活着，他就需要活出个样子来。
By the time Sarah was 14, three years after her transplant, she had gradually learned more details about her donor and his family. Letters had been exchanged. Her parents had gone down to meet Lucas' family. Sarah's parents had divorced by then. Her dad and step-mom hung a picture of Lucas on the mantle above their fireplace with other family photos. It was their way of honoring him, but it really upset Sarah.
到莎拉14岁时，移植手术三年后，她逐渐了解到更多关于捐赠者和他的家庭细节。他们交换了信件。她的父母在那时离婚了。她的父亲和继母把卢卡斯的照片挂在壁炉上方，和家庭合影放在一起。这是他们纪念他的方式，但这让莎拉非常难过。
I couldn't believe they did that. And even to this day, I can't believe they did that. That was, I thought, really insensitive. But that was their belief. They wanted to have it up. So I didn't go over to their house for a while. But that was how we solved that problem.
我不敢相信他们那样做。直到今天，我都不敢相信他们那样做。我认为那非常不敏感。但这那是他们的信仰。他们想把它放上去。所以我有一段时间没去他们家。但这就是我们解决那个问题的方式。
What was the part that was hard for you?
让你难过的部分是什么？
I don't know. It just made it real. I mean, it was already very real to me that I had my transplant. I have my scar and my stretch marks and I have to go to the doctors all the time. But it made it like it was a real person who died instead of me living. It was both.
我不知道。那让它变得真实了。我是说，我进行了移植手术对我来说已经很真实了。我有伤疤，有妊娠纹，我必须经常去看医生。但这让它感觉像是死了一个真实的人，而不是我活着。两者都有。
But Sarah's parents continued ever so gently to encourage her to learn more about Lucas and maybe even visit his family. Sarah kept saying she wasn't ready. But then an event came that changed her mind. The trial date was set for Lucas' killers. Sarah insisted on attending. She wanted to give Lucas' mom moral support, she said, even though the thought scared to death. She kept worrying, what if they don't like me?
但莎拉的父母依然非常温柔地鼓励她多了解卢卡斯，甚至去拜访他的家人。莎拉一直说她还没准备好。但后来发生了一件事让她改变了主意。卢卡斯凶手的审判日期定下来了。莎拉坚持要参加。她说她想给卢卡斯的妈妈以精神支持，即使那个想法让她害怕得要死。她不停地担心，如果他们不喜欢我怎么办？
Before I met them, I didn't want to disappoint them. And it might sound silly, but I kind of feel like, because of my transplant, and Lucas didn't get a chance to finish his life, I feel like I need to be good enough for two lives.
在见到他们之前，我不想让他们失望。这听起来可能很傻，但我有一种感觉，因为我的移植，而卢卡斯没有机会走完他的一生，我觉得我需要活得足够好，像两个人一样。
Did you want to meet Sarah right away?
你想立刻见到莎拉吗？
Kind of, yeah. But it felt weird because I didn't know if she was going to like our side of the family. We were different. She lives different, and we're different.
有点，是的。但这感觉很奇怪，因为我不知道她会不会喜欢我们这边的家人。我们不同。她生活的方式不同，我们也不同。
Culture?
文化差异？
Yeah. Because we're totally different. We're Mexicans. That's why.
是的。因为我们完全不同。我们是墨西哥人。这就是原因。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
（听不清）
Yeah. Because we're Mexicans, that's why. I don't know.
是的。因为我们是墨西哥人，这就是原因。我不知道。
Because he wasn't going to say it, I guess.
因为他不好意思说，我想。
Well, I was trying to figure it out. Because we were Mexican, that's why. And they were white.
嗯，我刚才在试图把它理清楚。因为我们是墨西哥人，这就是原因。而他们是白人。
Their first meeting took place at the home of Lucas' uncle the night before the trial began. The extended family was there, all the aunts and uncles. When Sarah walked in, Maria and Miguel rushed to her side.
他们的第一次见面是在审判开始的前一天晚上，在卢卡斯叔叔家里。大家庭都在，所有的阿姨和叔叔们都在。当莎拉走进去时，玛丽亚和米格尔冲向她的身边。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（说西班牙语）
She saw Sarah, and she couldn't believe that her son's heart was inside of Sarah. And she said that Sarah's mom told her that when she talked to Sarah to try not to cry in front of Sarah so that she wouldn't feel really bad.
她看到了莎拉，她无法相信她儿子的心脏就在莎拉身体里。她说莎拉的妈妈告诉她，当她和莎拉谈话时，尽量不要在莎拉面前哭，以免让她感到难过。
So what did Maria do?
那么玛丽亚做了什么？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（说西班牙语）
She started to cry, she said.
她说她开始哭了。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（说西班牙语）
And hug her.
然后拥抱了她。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（说西班牙语）
She wanted to hold her and not let go of her, she said, the whole day.
她说她想整天抱着她，不放手。
I had been told by their social worker that Maria, the mother, really wanted to feel Lucas' heart. And I had warned Sarah about that. I felt she needed to be prepared, so when she did meet the family, that this possibility would happen. Well, when she met them, and Sarah gave Maria a hug, Maria's head was right against Sarah's heart. And so Maria could actually feel her heartbeat.
社工告诉过我，玛丽亚，也就是母亲，真的想感受一下卢卡斯的心脏。我提醒过莎拉这点。我觉得她需要做好心理准备，所以当她真正见到家人时，这种情况可能会发生。好吧，当她见到他们，莎拉给了玛丽亚一个拥抱时，玛丽亚的头正好靠在莎拉的心脏上。所以玛丽亚实际上可以感觉到她的心跳。
The next day was the trial. Sarah sat next to Lucas' parents, holding Maria's hand.
第二天是审判。莎拉坐在卢卡斯的父母旁边，握着玛丽亚的手。
I'm used to watching Law & Order: SVU and the courtrooms are really big. And it wasn't like that at all. It was pretty small. And they went into very graphic terms about what happened and how he was murdered.
我习惯看《法律与秩序：特殊受害者》（Law & Order: SVU），那里的法庭非常大。而这里完全不是那样。它很小。他们非常详细地讲述了发生了什么以及他是如何被谋杀的。
Was that the first time you had heard in such graphic terms how he died?
那是你第一次听到如此详细的关于他如何死亡的描述吗？
Yes it was. And then they showed pictures. And my mom, she tried to pull me away. But I wanted to see it. I guess part of me that wanted to see it felt like Lucas had been through so much and that he was murdered so horribly that I shouldn't be a baby about what happened. Because if he had to die like that, why should I turn away from what happened?
是的。然后他们展示了照片。我妈妈，她试图把我拉开。但我想要看。我觉得我身上想要看的那部分觉得卢卡斯经历了太多，他被谋杀得太可怕了，我不应该对发生的事情像个小宝宝一样。因为如果他不得不那样死去，我为什么要对发生的事情退缩呢？
The two men that were on trial were really close to us. I think there was only three rows of seating for people that are watching the trial. So that was really strange, being that close. Even though they didn't know who I was, the people that were on trial, they looked at me a few times in the eyes. And it really scared me. I mean, I know they didn't know who I was or why I was there, but I felt like the person that they had murdered, part of him was in me.
接受审判的那两个人离我们很近。我想观看审判的人只有三排座位。所以那是极其奇怪的，离得那么近。尽管他们不知道我是谁，那两个受审的人，他们几次看着我的眼睛。那真的吓到我了。我是说，我知道他们不知道我是谁或者我为什么在那里，但我感觉像是我被他们谋杀的那个人，他的一部分在我身上。
When the jury convicted the two men of murder, something lifted for Sarah. That verdict of blame was placed clearly where it belonged. It was then that she says she stopped referring so much to Lucas' heart. She calls it her own heart now.
当陪审团裁定两人谋杀罪名成立时，莎拉感觉内心某种东西卸下了。那种责备的裁决被清楚地放在了它该在的地方。也就是那时她说她不再那么频繁地提到卢卡斯的心脏。她现在称它为她自己的心脏。
Still, in talking to Sarah, who's 19 now, it's clear she feels an enormous amount of pressure. She can't just take the second chance Lucas' family gave her. She has to constantly justify it, prove she's worthy of it. But it's unclear even to her what that means exactly, except that being an ordinary person isn't enough.
尽管如此，在和现年19岁的莎拉交谈时，很明显她感到了巨大的压力。她不能仅仅接受卢卡斯一家给她的第二次机会。她必须不断证明、证明她是配得上它的。但即使对她来说，那到底意味着什么也不清楚，除了作为一个普通人是不够的。
I don't know. It's just a constant fear in the back of my mind that when they see me grow up that they'll be like, wow, she really hasn't done anything great. This was-- you know, I don't know why they would think that. I don't know why I think that. But it would be like, wow, that was a bad choice.
我不知道。我脑后一直有一种持续的恐惧，当他们看到我长大时，他们会觉得，哇，她真的什么伟大的事情也没做。这……你知道，我不知道他们为什么要那样想。我不知道我为什么要那样想。但这就像是，哇，那是个糟糕的选择。
Lucas' family couldn't see things more differently.
卢卡斯的家人对此有着完全不同的看法。
She already made us proud already.
她已经让我们感到骄傲了。
Just being alive.
只要活着就好。
Oh, yeah. Just being alive and that's it. She is what she is. And that's the way--
哦，是的。只要活着，就这样。她就是她自己。而那是方式——
I think we'll always see her as perfect in our eyes, whatever she does.
我想在我们眼中，无论她做什么，她永远是完美的。
Whatever she wants to be, that's who she is. And that's good.
无论她想成为什么样的人，那就是她自己。那很好。
A few weeks ago, Sarah celebrated the eighth anniversary of her transplant. For Lucas' family, that's eight years of life that he's been able to give someone, eight years of proof that his death wasn't all in vain. For Sarah, it's eight years that she might not be alive if Lucas hadn't died.
几周前，莎拉庆祝了移植八周年纪念日。对于卢卡斯的家人来说，那是他能给某人的八年生命，八年证明他的死并非完全徒劳。对于莎拉来说，那是如果卢卡斯没死她可能就不会活着的八年。
The heart has been in her almost as long as it was in Lucas. It is her heart. And yet, every time she feels it slowing down as she drifts off to sleep, every time she's nervous and it speeds up, there's that reminder.
那颗心脏在她体内的时间几乎和在卢卡斯体内的时间一样长。那是她的心脏。然而，每次她感觉它在她入睡时慢下来，每次她紧张时它加速，都会有那样的提醒。
Jill Wolfson lives in Santa Cruz, California. She's currently finishing her newest novel for young adults, Cold Hands, Warm Heart , which comes out next year. Every 12 minutes, another name is added to the national registry of people who need organ donations. And each day in our country, 18 people die for a lack of donors.
吉尔·沃尔夫森住在加利福尼亚州圣克鲁斯。她目前正在完成她为年轻人写的新小说《冷手，暖心》（Cold Hands, Warm Heart），该书明年出版。每12分钟，国家器官捐献需求登记册上就会增加一个名字。每天在我国，有18人因缺乏捐献者而死亡。
Coming up, a casual offer in a restaurant takes on a life of its own. Actually, three lives of its own. These words I'm saying are going to make a lot more sense when we get to that act in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下里，餐厅里的一个随意提议有了自己的生命。实际上，是三个人的生命。当我们在一分钟后进入那一幕时，我说的话会更有意义。来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, Ties That Bind. We have stories of friendships, but these are friendships where even the friends themselves are not so sure about the friendships, which really is so many, many friendships. We've arrived at Act Three of our show.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来各种关于该主题的不同故事。今天的节目，《羁绊》。我们有关于友谊的故事，但这些友谊甚至连朋友自己都不是很确定，这实际上是很多、很多友谊的状态。我们已经进入了节目的第三幕。
Act Three, Lucy and the Bike Girl. In this next story, we're going to try something we have never tried before on our radio show. Reporter Hillary Frank interviewed this woman about an unusual online friendship. And everything you're going to hear from that interview is 100% true. But Hillary is also a fiction writer, and so she has taken this true story and she has expanded it into a piece of fiction.
第三幕，露西和骑车女孩。在接下来的故事中，我们将尝试一种我们在广播节目中从未尝试过的方法。记者希拉里·弗兰克（Hillary Frank）采访了一位女士，谈论了一段不寻常的网络友谊。你们在采访中听到的所有内容都是100%真实的。但希拉里也是一位小说家，所以她将这个真实的故事进行了扩充，变成了一部虚构作品。
So, OK, just to be clear, when you hear the taped interview, all true. Everything else Hillary says, up for grabs. OK, here we go.
所以，好的，为了清楚起见，当你听到录制的采访时，那是真实的。希拉里说的其他所有话，都是虚构的。好吧，我们开始。
This is the very first speed I do. Uh-uh-uh-uh-uh--
这是我做的第一个速度。嗯-嗯-嗯-嗯-嗯——
Lucy didn't have many friends growing up.
露西在成长过程中没什么朋友。
This is the final speed I do. Ah-ah-ah-ah-ah--
这是我做的最后一个速度。啊-啊-啊-啊-啊——
While other kids were running around playing on their lawns, she was inside, getting her chest pounded on to clear mucus out of her lungs.
当其他孩子在草坪上跑来跑去玩耍时，她却待在屋里，让人拍打她的胸部以清除肺部的粘液。
[COUGHING]
（咳嗽声）
She has cystic fibrosis. Now Lucy is 28. She lives in a tiny box of a house on the corner of two alleys in Philadelphia. Every day, while she's going through her morning routine, she hears this at the intersection outside her window. [BICYCLE BELL] The girl who rides the powder blue bike looks like Pippi Longstocking. She's got red braids, freckles, sometimes even striped socks. It's a strange look for a grown woman, but somehow she pulls it off.
她患有囊性纤维化。现在露西28岁了。她住在费城两条小巷拐角处一栋像小盒子一样的房子里。每天，当她进行晨间日常护理时，她会在窗外的十字路口听到这个。（自行车铃声）那个骑着淡蓝色自行车的女孩看起来像长袜子皮皮（Pippi Longstocking）。她留着红色的辫子，满脸雀斑，有时甚至穿着条纹袜子。这对成年女性来说是个奇怪的造型，但不知何故她驾驭得很好。
Each time she passes, Lucy runs to the window. She wants to call out to the girl. She wants to grab her by the wrist and bring her inside for a hot cup of tea. This girl doesn't know it, but Lucy is the person she chats with online every night.
每次她经过，露西都会跑到窗前。她想叫住那个女孩。她想抓住她的手腕，把她带进屋里喝杯热茶。这个女孩不知道，但露西就是她每晚在网上聊天的那个人。
That's more than I do with my closest friends.
这比我和最亲密的朋友交流得还要多。
Lucy and the Pippi Longstocking girl met a few weeks ago on a message board for people with CF.
露西和长袜子皮皮女孩几周前在一个囊性纤维化（CF）病友的留言板上认识了。
We basically found each other through these posts that were about pregnancy.
我们基本上是通过关于怀孕的帖子找到对方的。
The girl had posted her picture, and Lucy recognized her braids right away.
那个女孩发了照片，露西一眼就认出了她的辫子。
--and picked up on the fact that we were both trying to conceive at the same time.
——并注意到我们都在同一时间尝试受孕。
Lucy and the bike girl quickly realized they'd need to chat privately. Other people on the message board got judgmental of them, told them they should get their tubes tied. Women with CF, they said, should not have babies. A baby is basically a big ball of germs. And what CF patient in their right mind would invite a big ball of germs into their house? Actually, this is pretty close to what Lucy's doctor said, too.
露西和骑车女孩很快意识到她们需要私下聊天。留言板上的其他人对她们评头论足，告诉她们应该去结扎。他们说，患有CF的女性不应该生孩子。孩子基本上就是一个巨大的细菌球。而且哪个脑子正常的CF患者会邀请一个巨大的细菌球进屋？事实上，这和露西医生的说法也差不多。
He was like, well, if you're really going to do this-- which I wish I could convince you not to-- I guess now is better than later. And I'd remember coming home and crying and going for a run, just to prove him wrong, or whatever, that I was healthy and that I would be able to do this.
他说，嗯，如果你真的要这么做——我真希望我能说服你不要——我想现在比以后好。我记得回到家哭着去跑步，只是为了向他证明他是错的，或者什么，证明我很健康，我有能力做到这点。
[BICYCLE BELL]
（自行车铃声）
That night, about an hour after Lucy heard the bell pass by her house, she went online and complained to the bike girl about her doctor. The bike girl couldn't believe it. This was almost word for word what her doctor had told her just a couple days ago. "Nobody gets it," Lucy typed. "Even my best friend said I was making the biggest mistake of my life."
那天晚上，在露西听到铃声经过她家大约一小时后，她上线并向骑车女孩抱怨她的医生。骑车女孩简直不敢相信。这几乎就是她的医生几天前对她说过的话，一字不差。“没人懂，”露西打字道。“甚至我最好的朋友都说我犯了人生中最大的错误。”
"I hate your best friend," the bike girl typed back. Lucy didn't know how to respond to that. Her first instinct was to tell the bike girl not to judge Miranda. She didn't even know her.
“我恨你最好的朋友，”骑车女孩回打道。露西不知道该如何回应。她的第一反应是告诉骑车女孩不要评判米兰达（Miranda）。她甚至都不认识她。
But she found herself typing the words, "I do, too." And then she just spilled her guts. She told the bike girl how her dad and Miranda's dad had been in the army together. How their mothers had seen the Beatles together. How when she and Miranda were girls, they'd concoct special shampoos from all the bottles in their bathroom cabinets. And how they'd once lost little chunks of hair because they didn't know what Nair was.
但她发现自己打出了，“我也恨。”然后她就把自己的心事全倒出来了。她告诉骑车女孩她爸爸和米兰达的爸爸是如何在军队里当战友的。她们的妈妈是如何一起看过披头士乐队的。她们小时候是如何用洗手间柜子里所有的瓶子调制特殊洗发水的。她们又是如何因为不知道什么是脱毛膏（Nair）而损失了一小撮头发的。
But by high school, things had changed. Miranda made Lucy feel bad for being in honors classes, for having a boyfriend, and now, for being married. Miranda was always planning girls' nights out for just the two of them. She'd get drunk and call Lucy her best friend. But it was clear to Lucy that Miranda didn't get her at all.
但到了高中，一切都变了。米兰达让露西因为选修荣誉课程、因为有男朋友，以及现在因为结婚而感到难受。米兰达总是策划只有她们两人的女孩之夜。她会喝醉并称露西为最好的朋友。但露西很清楚，米兰达一点都不了解她。
Going to a smoky bar, that kind of thing isn't worth it. Staying out late, how much fun is it really going to be? It might take off four years of my life.
去烟雾缭绕的酒吧之类的地方不值得。熬夜能有多大的乐趣呢？那可能会让我少活四年。
"I wish I could hug you," the bike girl typed.
“我真希望我能抱抱你，”骑车女孩打字道。
"I wish we could just hang out," Lucy typed back, "like real friends."
“我真希望我们能聚在一起，”露西回打道，“像真正的朋友那样。”
"I wish we could play Connect Four," the bike girl wrote.
“我真希望我们能玩连连看（Connect Four），”骑车女孩写道。
"Yeah," Lucy answered, "and give each other pedicures." Lucy had an urge to run down the street with nail polish, knock on the girl's door, and tell her they were neighbors. But she couldn't. Because that type of proximity would be too dangerous.
“是的，”露西回答，“然后互相做脚部护理。”露西有一种冲动，想拿着指甲油跑到街上，敲响女孩的门，告诉她她们是邻居。但她不能。因为那样的近距离接触太危险了。
Online, we have signatures, and hers says that she has B. cepacia.
在网上，我们有签名档，她的签名写着她有洋葱伯克霍尔德氏菌（B. cepacia）。
B. cepacia is a type of bacteria that lives in soil and water and rotting onions. It's not harmful to most of us. But for people with CF, B. cepacia germs act as a superbug, colonizing in their lungs.
洋葱伯克霍尔德氏菌是一种生活在土壤、水和腐烂洋葱里的细菌。对我们大多数人来说它无害。但对于CF患者来说，它的细菌表现为一种超级细菌，在肺部定殖。
Colonizing means that you have it in your lungs forever. Like, it has set up shop big time.
定殖意味着它会永远留在你的肺里。就像它在那里安了家一样。
And if one person with CF is colonizing B. cepacia, it's a bad idea for them to be around another person with CF. In fact, people with CF are never supposed to come within three feet of each other, even at the doctor's office.
如果一个患有CF的人定殖了洋葱伯克霍尔德氏菌，那么他们和另一个患有CF的人在一起是个坏主意。事实上，CF患者从不被允许在三英尺内接触，即使是在医生的办公室里。
The fear is that I would inhale some of these germs, or they would get on my hands. And suddenly, then you get sick. And it's especially virile because there are few antibiotics that work against it. When you are diagnosed with having B. cepacia in your lungs, your life expectancy is cut in half.
恐惧是我会吸入一些这些细菌，或者它们会沾到我的手上。然后突然间你就病了。它特别顽强，因为很少有抗生素对它有效。当你被诊断出肺部有洋葱伯克霍尔德氏菌时，你的预期寿命会减少一半。
When we both got pregnant within weeks of each other, it was like, oh my gosh, I'm never going to get to be able to see your kid. That tore me up a bit. And I was thinking about Fairmount Park. And I was like, "oh, we could stand three feet apart. And I could make sure I'm upwind of her." I think that might have even been in a dream. And I'm like, oh, I could hold her kid. And then she can touch my kid. But then I realized, I'm like, yeah, this is not going to happen. Unless we both showed up in HazMat suits or something.
当我们都在几周内怀孕时，那种感觉是，哦天哪，我永远没机会见到你的孩子了。那让我有点痛苦。我当时在想费尔芒特公园（Fairmount Park）。我说，“哦，我们可以站得三英尺远。我可以确保在她的上风处。”我想那甚至可能是在梦里。我说，噢，我可以抱她的孩子。然后她可以摸我的孩子。但我意识到，我对自己说，是的，这不可能发生。除非我们俩都穿着防护服之类的。
As Lucy's belly grew, she heard the bike bell less and less. Until finally, it stopped entirely. She was still chatting with the bike girl most nights. But she felt desperate for more contact. She bought a onesie with a drawing of a peanut and wrapped it up to send to the bike girl, with no return address, of course. But she never sent the package.
随着露西的肚子一天天大起来，她听到自行车铃声的次数越来越少。直到最后，完全消失了。她大多数晚上还在和骑车女孩聊天。但她渴望更多的接触。她买了一件印着花生图案的连体衣，包起来准备寄给骑车女孩，当然没有回邮地址。但她从来没寄出过那个包裹。
Because it's almost like anthrax. Does she really want to receive something from me? It's weird. I mean, I could have something that they haven't found yet. And I could have it and she couldn't. And it's just not a good idea.
因为它几乎就像炭疽。她真的想收到我的东西吗？这太奇怪了。我是说，我可能带有他们还没发现的东西。我可以有它，但她不能。这真不是个好主意。
Halloween rolled around. Lately, Lucy had been avoiding her kinda-sorta best friend Miranda's phone calls, and the guilt was weighing on her. So when Miranda invited her to a costume party, she agreed to go. Miranda had picked the costumes. Lucy would be a pregnant lady in labor, and Miranda would be her midwife, her sexy midwife.
万圣节到了。最近，露西一直在躲避她那个所谓最好的朋友米兰达的电话，负罪感一直折磨着她。所以当米兰达邀请她去化装舞会时，她同意了。米兰达选了服装。露西要扮成一个临盆的孕妇，而米兰达要扮成她的助产士，性感的助产士。
Miranda was late, as usual. Lucy waited on her couch in a hospital gown made from an old sheet, watching her husband greet trick-or-treaters in his scuba diver costume. She started to worry about getting home in time for her evening lung treatment. She wished that she was going to this party with the bike girl. Wouldn't it be nice if they could come home and do their treatments together? And then, Lucy had an idea.
米兰达照例迟到了。露西坐在用旧床单做的病号服里，在沙发上等着，看着她的丈夫穿着潜水员服装问候玩“不给糖就捣蛋”的孩子们。她开始担心能不能及时赶回家进行晚上的肺部护理。她希望自己能和骑车女孩一起去参加聚会。如果她们能一起回家做护理那该多好？然后，露西有个主意。
Well, screw it. Life is too short. If I want to meet her, I'll meet her.
好吧，管它呢。人生苦短。如果我想见她，我就见她。
Lucy walked over to her husband and took off his scuba mask, then put it over her own head. "Be right back," she told him and walked out the door. As she hurried up the dark alley, she wondered if the bike girl would be dressed as Pippi Longstocking. Was she Pippi every year?
露西走到丈夫身边，摘下了他的潜水面罩，然后戴在了自己头上。“马上回来，”她告诉他，然后走了出去。当她匆忙穿过黑暗的小巷时，她想知道那个骑车女孩会不会打扮成长袜子皮皮。她每年都是皮皮吗？
When she got to the bike girl's house, she stared at the buzzer. Her breaths were loud inside her mask. Her heart was beating in her brain. She felt something tugging at her sheet. She looked down and saw a little pack of superheroes crowded around her waist. "You gonna ring it, lady?" the Incredible Hulk asked her.
当她走到骑车女孩家时，她盯着门铃。她的呼吸在面具里声音很响。她的心在脑子里跳动。她感到有什么东西在扯她的床单。她低头一看，看到一群小超级英雄围在她的腰间。“你要按门铃吗，女士？”那个绿巨人（Incredible Hulk）问她。
Lucy jumped back and shook her head. She didn't even wait for the door to open before heading home. She squinted down the street and saw a scuba diver without his mask, shrugging at a sexy midwife. The sexy midwife stomped her high-heeled boots and pointed at her watch, then got in her car and drove off.
露西跳回一步，摇了摇头。她甚至没等门打开就回家了。她眯着眼睛向街那头望去，看到一个摘下面罩的潜水员，正对着一个性感的助产士耸肩。性感的助产士跺着高跟鞋，指着表，然后钻进车里开走了。
Lucy smiled. In a way, she was glad she had chickened out with the bike girl. Things with her were so easy. Maybe meeting in person would just make them more complicated.
露西笑了。在某种程度上，她很高兴自己没敢去见骑车女孩。和她在一起的感觉太轻松了。也许见面只会让一切变得更复杂。
I know we won't always be in touch like we are right now, every day. If we can just keep in touch, though, I think it's going to be great. Because I think we have something unusual.
我知道我们不会一直像现在这样每天保持联系。只要我们能保持联系，我就觉得那会很棒。因为我觉得我们有着非比寻常的关系。
That night, when the bike girl got online, Lucy was waiting by her computer with nail polish. She told the bike girl to go get some, too. And they sat beside their chat screens, painting their toenails, one after the other.
那天晚上，当骑车女孩上线时，露西正带着指甲油在电脑前等她。她告诉骑车女孩也去拿一些。于是她们坐在聊天屏幕前，一个接一个地涂着脚趾甲。
Hillary Frank is the author of the young adult novel, Better than Running at Night . She lives in Philadelphia.
希拉里·弗兰克是年轻成人小说《比晚上跑步更好》（Better than Running at Night）的作者。她住在费城。
[SONG - "ME AND MY FRIEND" BY JULIE DOIRON]
（歌曲 - 朱莉·多隆（Julie Doiron）的《我和我的朋友》（Me and My Friend））
Act Four, David and Andi. This last story we have today about are-we-real-friends kinds of friendships begins in a restaurant with a fertility doctor and a waitress.
第四幕，大卫和安迪。我们今天关于“我们是真朋友吗”这种友谊的最后一个故事，始于一家餐厅，主角是一位生育医生和一位女服务员。
I'm David Kallenberger. I'm Program Director of the Bennett Fertility Institute.
我是大卫·卡伦伯格（David Kallenberger）。我是贝内特生育研究所（Bennett Fertility Institute）的项目主任。
My name is Andi Knox, born and raised in New Orleans. I worked at Galatoire's, which is a very famous restaurant in New Orleans. And my husband and I were trying to get pregnant for about three years. I was seeing a fertility specialist. He came in one night and brought in a drug rep. Her name is Myra Crawford. And we just hit it off. She's like, your next go around, I'll give you your drugs. I'll take care of that for you. And I was like, oh, well, that's great.
我叫安迪·诺克斯（Andi Knox），在新奥尔良出生长大。我在加拉图瓦餐厅（Galatoire's）工作，那是新奥尔良一家非常有名的餐厅。我和我丈夫尝试怀孕大约三年了。我一直在看生育专家。他有一天晚上带着一位医药代表进来了。她叫迈拉·克劳福德（Myra Crawford）。我们一见如故。她说，你下次治疗的时候，我会给你提供药。我会为你处理好。我说，噢，那太好了。
We were in New Orleans meeting a friend of ours. She happens to be a drug rep that sells fertility drugs. And we were having breakfast at Galatoire's. And she had asked for Andi Knox to wait on us, who we assumed was a friend of hers. She knew she was having some fertility issues and was under treatment at a fertility institute in New Orleans that got wiped away in Katrina.
我们在新奥尔良见一位朋友。她正好是销售生育药物的医药代表。我们当时在加拉图瓦餐厅吃早餐。她曾要求安迪·诺克斯接待我们，我们假定她是她的朋友。她知道她有一些生育问题，并且正在新奥尔良的一家生育研究所接受治疗，那家研究所在卡特里娜飓风中被毁了。
She brought the Kallenbergers in, Jenny and David Kallenberger. I never met these people, only had met Myra just a few times, and waited on them. And we were talking about doing the in vitro fertilization.
她把卡伦伯格夫妇，珍妮（Jenny）和大卫·卡伦伯格带了进来。我从未见过这些人，只是见过迈拉几次，然后接待了他们。我们当时正在谈论做体外受精。
They started talking a little bit. And she said, well, you've got to go to Dr. Kallenberger's program in Oklahoma City, because they have some of the best results in the country. And my wife then popped up and said, yeah, you can just stay with us if you come. And I looked at her kind of funny.
他们开始聊起来。她说，嗯，你必须去俄克拉何马城大卫·卡伦伯格医生的项目，因为他们拥有全国最好的结果。然后我妻子突然插话说，是的，如果你来的话可以住我们家。我有点奇怪地看着她。
Jenny, out of the blue, just met her, was like, well, yeah, you can come up to Oklahoma and stay at our house. And David will do everything. He'll do the whole thing for you. And I was just like, oh, OK. And he kind of chimed in, and said, well, yeah--
珍妮，突如其来，刚认识她，就说，嗯，是的，你可以来俄克拉何马州，住我们家。大卫会处理一切。他会为你做整个手术。我当时就是，噢，好吧。他顺着话茬说，嗯，是的——
--if you'd like to send me your records, I'll be glad to go over them and give you my opinion of what you need to have done. So she left, and I looked at my wife and said, do you realize what you just did? And she goes, well, she'd never take us up on that.
——如果你愿意寄给我你的病历，我很乐意查看它们，并给出我关于你需要做什么的建议。她走了，我看着我妻子说，你知道你刚才做了什么吗？她说，嗯，她才不会当真呢。
Well, I actually sent my records to him.
好吧，我确实把病历寄给他了。
A week later, I got a nice letter from Andi with her record. And it said, you're so kind to do this for me. And I've been looking you up on the internet. And Myra's right. You have really great results. And if your offer's sincere, I'd love to take you up on it. So I call Jenny and I say, well, guess what? That little offer you made as a quip, she's going to take us up on it.
一周后，我收到了安迪的一封好信。信里说，你这样做太好了。我一直在网上查你。迈拉说得对。你的结果真的很好。如果你的提议是真诚的，我很想接受它。于是我给珍妮打电话说，嗯，猜猜怎么着？你开玩笑提出的那个小提议，她当真了。
And so we said, well, she's a friend of Myra's. And so we called Myra and told her and said, so you know her pretty well? She goes, no, I really don't know her. She waits on me at Galatoire's and does a good job.
我们说，好吧，她是迈拉的朋友。所以我们给迈拉打电话说了这件事，说，所以你很了解她吗？她说，不，我真的不太了解她。她在我工作的加拉图瓦餐厅当服务员，工作做得很好。
It took me about two months to make the decision to actually go to a strange place-- I had never been to Oklahoma, didn't know anyone there-- to stay with some stranger and do this in vitro fertilization.
我花了大约两个月做决定，去一个陌生的地方——我从没去过俄克拉何马州，在那儿不认识任何人——去住在一个陌生人家里，做这个体外受精。
And this isn't a short visit. This is a three-and-a-half-week visit, by the time you start, she gets there, and she has to stay after embryos are transferred and all. And so I go, OK, this is going to be real interesting.
而且这不是一个短暂的访问。这是一个三周半的访问，等你开始，她到达那里，她必须在胚胎移植后留下等等。所以我说，噢，这会非常有趣。
And everybody was like, this is kind of weird. You're staying at his house.
每个人都觉得，这太奇怪了。你住在他的房子里。
And I've never had a patient stay with us before, unless it was a relative or something.
我以前从没让病人住过我们家，除非是亲戚之类的。
Everybody's like, why is this doctor doing this? I'm like, I don't know.
每个人都问，为什么这个医生要这样做？我说，我不知道。
Long story short, over time, she and Jenny, my wife, got to be really close and good friends and spent time in the kitchen cooking together and sharing recipes. And she underwent IVF.
长话短说，随着时间推移，她和珍妮，也就是我妻子，变得非常亲近，成了好朋友，花时间在厨房里一起做饭、分享食谱。她接受了体外受精。
Came home about seven days later, took the pregnancy test and found out that both eggs took. Five and a half weeks, we did an ultrasound, found out that it was twins, but we saw something else. And then nine and a half weeks, it was triplets.
大约七天后回到家，做了验孕测试发现两个卵子都成了。五个半星期后，我们做了超声波，发现是双胞胎，但我们看到了别的东西。然后在九个半星期后，变成了三胞胎。
Well, it started off as a very weird situation that ended up being a very positive event.
嗯，它始于一个非常奇怪的情况，最终变成了一个非常积极的事件。
I think about these people every day. They are such a big part of my life. I mean, I have three babies because of them.
我每天都会想起这些人。他们是我生命中重要的一部分。我是说，因为他们我有了三个宝宝。
Jenny-- at the initial part when I said, well, we're going to have these guests-- she goes, well, that can be our payback for Katrina.
珍妮——在最初我说，嗯，我们将有这些客人时——她说，嗯，那可以作为我们对卡特里娜飓风的补偿。
My son's name is Kallen, after Dr. Kallenberger. And my middle daughter's name is Emma, which is a family name. And Ava is actually Dr. Kallenberger's niece.
我儿子的名字叫卡伦（Kallen），是以卡伦伯格医生的名字命名的。我中间那个女儿的名字叫艾玛（Emma），是一个家族名。而艾娃（Ava）实际上是卡伦伯格医生的侄女。
Jenny just sent her a shower gift. And it has these little baby things kids wear that has their name on the front, and over the butt it has "Made in Oklahoma."
珍妮刚给她送了一份送礼会礼物。里面有这些小宝宝穿的东西，前面写着他们的名字，屁股上面写着“俄克拉何马制造”。
Dr. David Kallenberger and Andi Knox. Their story was put together by Scott Gurian at KGOU in Norman, Oklahoma.
大卫·卡伦伯格医生和安迪·诺克斯。他们的故事由俄克拉何马州诺曼市KGOU电台的斯科特·古里安（Scott Gurian）整理。
Well, our program was produced today by our senior producer, Julie Snyder, with Alex Blumberg, Jane Feltes, John Jeter, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Production help from Seth Lind and Bruce Wallace. Music help from Jessica Hopper.
嗯，我们的节目今天由我们的资深制片人朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）制作，参与人员还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、简·费尔特斯（Jane Feltes）、约翰·杰特（John Jeter）、莎拉·科尼格（Sarah Koenig）、丽莎·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、阿丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）。阿德里安娜·马修韦茨（Adrianne Mathiowetz）负责我们的网站。塞思·林德（Seth Lind）和布鲁斯·华莱士（Bruce Wallace）提供了制作帮助。杰西卡·霍珀（Jessica Hopper）提供了音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
（致谢）
Our website, where you can get our free weekly podcast, or listen to any of our old programs for absolutely free, www.thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站，在那里你可以获取我们免费的每周播客，或者免费收听我们以前的任何节目，www.thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
（资助方致谢）
WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Torey Malatia. Every time he hands me my paycheck, he has very helpful advice about how I should spend that money.
我们节目的WBEZ管理监督由我们的老板托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）负责。每次他给我发工资时，他都会提供非常有用的建议，关于我应该如何花掉那些钱。
Go to restaurants, go to fitness club.
去餐厅，去健身俱乐部。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
国际公共广播电台。